interesting story today st. Louis
post-dispatch and Benjamin Hawkman has
been covering this story can you sum
this up for our audience Benjamin of
exactly what has happened with this High
School in st. Louis pretty crazy
football game for fighting i junked it
you can't play the next game
bill Jackson star running back for Carla
Ritter got in a fight and was ejected
and suspended after the final game of
last season so he was not allowed to
play in the first game of this season
playing a very tough opponent out of
Chicago Nazareth and so the guy couldn't
play right except he did the cook I gave
him a jersey of a different player and
put him out there and sure enough bill
Jackson did not play that game when
Marvin Burks had a big game and I got an
interception a 56 yard touchdown
nice game for this new car well David
qui doll the post-dispatch figured it
out look at some photos later in the
season I realize a tattoo on this new
guy Marvin works was the same tattoo on
the star running back Phil Jackson
played the rest of the games so far this
season
all right so what happened what's the
punishment the season has been canceled
and the winds by Cardinal Ritter have
been forfeited is anybody come forward
to talk about this well that's a great
question because just last night to the
coach his name is Brandon Gregory and
he's done a lot of interviews around st.
Louis but he would not go into any
details whatsoever about what motivated
him to make this decision why he did
this and why he put his students and
athletes in a situation where they're
basically living a lie and the holding
onto a lie yeah but he had a fake player
out there he hasn't even come forward to
admit that
oh yes he did admit that mistakes were
made if I may and he did admit that he
said just last night that he was doing
it for the player not for the team and
understand all understandable but what
he's saying is he wanted the kid to play
against this top-notch opponent it's
good for recruiting tapes and stuff but
the reality is yeah the kid should not
have been allowed to play in the game he
was supposed to be suspended and he put
a fake number of a different number of
them but he flared the game anybody back
in the coach here that there's a lot of
people in in that community are backing
the coast because they're kind of saying
like they're kind of sweeping it under
the rug or under the artificial high
school curve these are so many other
great things for this community for this
team and older players are talking about
it I wouldn't have been in college right
now there's a college football player
I'm in college right now for free what a
scholarship thanks to coach Gregory I
went in here because of him and that's a
true statement but the fire the passion
of the code clearly backfired of this
situation as the coach lost who's John
yeah correct how good is this team are
we talking about its state championship
caliber team that's the thing I buried
the lead there this was not only the
best team in st. Louis but MaxPreps had
them ranked as the number one small
school in the nation this is a fantastic
team Cardinal Ritter their season is
over no senior night nope oh my god
is there another shoe to drop on this
Benjamin I I don't think so the reality
is they're going to have to start from
scratch and I are a new coach a new
staff and of course the victims in this
are the kids and I mean the senior night
is a special night for so many high
school anaphase these seniors won't get
to have that of course playing for the
state championship they were in a state
title game last year lost the whole
summer they prepared to come back and
get vengeance and
win the state championship this year
well now they won't get you because of
coach that greedy for more Dan Patrick
show tune in to audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]